[Music]
either the first ships to take off in
the airborne invasion of part of Europe
just minutes after midnight on the 6th
of June the first wave of decoder
aircraft crossed the channel and dropped
thousands of paratroopers into France
behind enemy lines 75 years later that
scene was repeated in memory of them we
made the journey over in a world war 2
Dakota from duxford in Cambridge flying
in formation with others that had
gathered from all over the world and our
martyr of the skies a thing of wonder
then and now some troopers dropping down
in their shoes the Germans were hosing
was pretty badly with machine pistols
and we got a couple of hits from a
bigger gun nothing very big we flew low
over the East of England escorted by
Spitfires and watched by thousands below
the paratroopers today wore the uniform
and carried the kit of back then they
might not have fallen into the teeth of
the enemy or under reeking fire from the
Nazis below but they jumped in memory of
those that did I went to round Ville
cemetery yesterday and there were
private John's Ernie was 16 years old
just thinking about him what he'd have
been thinking when you were jumping you
can't imagine what they what I've been
going through their heads they're
jumping into a high probability or death
and a 16 year old kids so just thinking
about hearts to be honest two of those
who jumped with veterans themselves
Harry and Jacque
it's brave in old age as they were as
young men it was a different world then
it's edited the world that required
young minimum like myself to to be
prepared to die for for a civilization
that was worth living we drop them today
maybe she's bridging chilling in the
native 5th of June General Eisenhower
said it was the Dakota that won the war
on that night they flew the first wave
in in the days and weeks after they
brought the wounded back you'll notice
with d-day aircraft it will have these
black and white stripes on them painted
either on the fuselage or on the wing
now back in the day ground crew would
get a broom bucket of white paint bucket
and black paint and just slop them on
quickly the point of them was to
identify these aircraft as friendly
aircraft so that the Allied ships and
the English Channel below wouldn't
shooter them simple but it largely
worked
200,000 men crossed the channel that
night over the sea and in the air if
they'd look back this would have been
their last sight of home but they didn't
look back they went on and changed the
world
Alistair bunker Sky News in France